what are the biggest challenge in see
both face trying to bring the digital
Rolex to life many of the biggest
challenges for me have been convincing
people that it's possible even that it's
for a very long time it was convincing
various companies that I wanted to
partner with that this was a viable
market and then the Kickstarter campaign
proved the market exists and is very
enthusiastic because we sold out of
cameras in 36 hours so it was yeah a
great response from Kickstarter and from
the market and and then convincing other
people who you know were online like Stu
mashup that has a very possible popular
blog called Pro loss convincing people
like him that we actually could do this
that it was possible that a black magic
actually helped us in that way once
black magic announced a similar priced
raw for my camera suddenly people were
like okay maybe it is possible but
before that they were saying how is this
possible you know none of the other
camera companies seem to think they can
do it why do you think you can do this
and there was a lot of convincing people
though that not only was it technically
possible but that we can
doing that there was a market for
and I think that
that the camera community the camera
enthusiasts cinematographer community
like they can be very obsessive and they
can be very vicious at times and you
know that was something that we faced
very early was they just assume it
couldn't be done and it was sort of a
nasty realization over time that it
wasn't that it couldn't be done but it
was
camera companies didn't want to do it
you know there were other companies that
have promised similar products that
hadn't ever delivered on that or there's
you know a price difference when that
you know did materialize and I think
people felt you know again people have
to adapt themselves in their projects to
the cameras they have the capability of
buying and I think that you know they
had been led to believe that it wasn't
physically possible to create a nice you
know high quality camera for a lower
price and so when we're like well yeah
it's totally possible I think people
felt a little bit you know weird or
betrayed or there's all these like high
emotions that then got sort of siphoned
down to us that we just didn't expect at
all so that's that's been hard as you
know keeping track of
you know if people are upset why they're
upset or they you know
we can't do it why they think we can't
do it
make an effort to sort of engage with
people and discuss things with them and
we've had really good success with that
I think what are their problems for say
I mean other than the general problem of
things take longer than you think they
will because we're a small team if one
small thing goes wrong and we have to
start over it can sometimes take longer
there obviously it would for a bigger
company but generally it's it's been run
of the mill I don't think
setbacks we have
sure drama nothing
you know because the thing is are again
are we said this many times before but
our Kickstarter was the tail end of you
know for me months and 40 years of
effort put into this project and so we
were very clear on what steps needed to
be taken to get us where we wanted to go
we talked briefly about the problems in
being behind the curve and ahead of the
curve any words of advice to other
people that are in a similar position
maybe being ahead of the curve either
having people doubt you for whatever
reason not wanting things made and just
the polite persistence that you talked
about what are some of the things that
so we can do whatever it is whether
they're it's an idea it's a product yeah
research we did while I was still at my
last company we did nine months of
research before we talked to anybody
else about this before we approached any
other partner companies anything like
that there are a huge amount of reports
sometimes you have to pay for them
several hundred dollars for various
reports and then I had my research
assistant Toby who works with us now at
this company also was on the phone with
film schools and everybody that had to
do with a film film world to understand
the market that we would go
into and it was a lot of work we have to
do a lot block and in terms of being a
header behind you know one thing that we
did was find you know a product that
people had wanted that people have been
talking about for years that didn't
exist and making that object that people
want so it's not necessarily something
that's so far advanced that people can't
think of it being possible but finding
something that people are sort of
annoyed that they don't have already and
try to create that and build onto it
features that you know people might use
or that are slightly forward thinking
you know we have a USB 3 port you know
stuff like that the sort of like
future-proof is kind of a silly term
because you can't truly future-proof
thing but trying to figure out what the
trends and Technology are what is being
picked up by other companies and being
promoted as new formats and tried to
integrate that into a package so that by
the time it appears it's something that
you know is exactly what should be on
the horizon or at what people six months
ago would have seen on the horizon
there's a book about it it's called blue
ocean strategies and it's all about how
to create a unique offering in an
existing market place and set yourself
apart from consumers making competition
irrelevant
you